I mean, this hurts to look at you
I just have to tell you guys.
You're so lovely and you're so beautifully dressed.
And the fact that you're all from like tallest to smallest,
I can't handle it.
How did you guys get into the cookie business?
First, we went to go ask her mom
would she approved of the business.
Then told us to go sit down with our dad.
And our dad, eventually he agreed to do it.
And we came up with the name and the logo,
and then it went off from there.
Joshua, what has it been like working with your brothers
and starting a business?
Well, it's been really fun to be able
to work with my brothers, my mom and my dad.
And another thing that I really love is that
we're inspiring kids and adults across the world
to be entrepreneurs.
(cheering and applause)
That's so wise.
Micah, you guys are going to school
and running a successful business.
How are you managing it all?
Well, how we're doing this is
we do our schoolwork first, then we bake the cookies.
("awws" from audience)
Caleb, what are you going to do
with the money you're making?
Well, actually we created another business
called Kidpreneur Expo, which is an online platform
that allows kidpreneurs to advertise and market
in their business.
(cheering and applause)
That's really smart.
I learned early that marketing and advertising
is very important because it's how you tell your story.
And it's a great way for you to take control
but also make sure it's exactly the way you see it.
Isaiah, you are all such cool dudes.
What would you tell someone who thought baking
was a girl thing?
Well, Drew, that's an awesome question.
Let's say in my trip of imagination
you're on a Saturday morning having some coffee
probably just relaxing, and you have your cookies baking
in the oven at 350 degrees.
Then when they get out, you take a bite
and ooey, gooey chocolate all over your mouth.
And another thing, Drew,
one of our biggest supporters was our grandfather.
And he would always tell us whatever you put your mind to,
you can always do it.
I am so excited to be talking to you guys.
And I know that you sent us some of your yummy cookies.
Okay, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
What do we have?
Walk me through it, gentlemen.
All right, so we have the two face,
which is double dark chocolate mixed with chocolate chip.
Then we have chocolate chip, snicker doodle,
then there's cookies and cream, Papa's white chocolate
macadamia nut that was named after our grandfather
because he loved macadamia nuts.
And then oatmeal.
Hmm, hmm, hmm-hmm.
The cookie that we picked up for you, Drew
is Drew's ET cookie, which means extra tasty!
(cheering and applause)
I love it!
Oh gosh, you gentlemen are so handsome and so talented.
Hm, oh my gosh.
[Billinglea Brother] In the Drew cookies there's pecans,
toffee and chocolate chip.
I must tell you guys, these are truly some
of the best cookies I've ever had in my life.
And I'm not just saying that.
These are perfect.
Their texture is exactly what you dream of.
And there are so many different flavors
from all the different nuts.
They're incredible.
You guys have made an extraordinary product, and I know
that one of your goals is to sell your cookies nationwide.
And I actually heard that you would love to sell in a store.
And I reached out to the owners of Slim and Husky's,
the first Black-owned pizza franchise in the country.
We love that place, we go there all the time.
Their food is great.
Their successful pizza empire has stores nationwide,
and I would love to welcome in the wonderful co-owners
of Slim and Husky's, Clint, EJ, and Derek.
(cheering and applause)
What's up fellas?
It is great to meet you guys.
We wanted to hop on and say congratulations
on all you guys' success.
You guys are true leaders for your communities
and your families.
I just want to tell you to keep on going.
The best is yet to come for you guys.
Man, we just want you guys to know if you focus,
continue doing what you love
with the people that you love, man
you can't go wrong so much success to you guys.
What we're going to do is allow you guys
sell your cookies in out Atlanta stores.
How does that sound?
(cheering and applause)
That's great, let's go!
Awesome, awesome.
So what we'll do is we'll work together
on a marketing strategy and we'll figure out
how to make it all work.
That sound good?
Yeah, great.
Thank you for having us.
We're going to, obviously if we could be so lucky
to have each and every one of you
up on our website, it's thedrewbarrymoreshow.com,
shining lights on your businesses.
We love all of you and everything that you're doing
in your business communities as well
as being really smart businessmen.
Thank you so much.
But Drew, you know what would be good?
If we did an exclusive Slim and Husky's special cookie.
(cheering and applause)
We like that, we love that.
I'm so grateful to Clint and EJ and Derek
for taking you guys on and the collaboration
that you're going to have in your near future.
Thank you gentlemen, for that opportunity
for these incredible gentlemen, the Yummy Brothers.
Thank you.
Thank you, Drew.
All right, keep us posted all along the way.
(lively music)